nichtsdestotrotz ist das thema klima
eines was uns hier am tisch natürlich
umtreibt was viele zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer umtreibt was auch sie umtreibt
und treibt auch nicht aber sie haben es
am anfang gesagt es gibt natürlich
maßnahmen die vielleicht trotz allem und
trotz der intention darauf vielleicht
nicht einzahlen deswegen ich bin zurzeit
kein besonders großer fan des nur 1 euro
tickets und zwar weil ich denke dass es
einfach seine ja im prinzip die ziele
die sie erreichen soll verfehlt wird es
zum einen natürlich vielleicht auch
steigende verbraucherpreise
anzugehen und da eben entlastung zu
schaffen für die bürgerinnen und bürger
und zum anderen eben so zu sagen
irgendwie so eine bewegung von der
straße weg hinauf die schiene und auf
den öffentlichen nahverkehr zu
initiieren und meines erachtens sind das
ist es aber ein sehr
kurzfristig gedacht
ja eigentlich dies kann maßnahme die uns
nirgendwohin bringen wird und ich würde
mich freuen wenn wir das in deutschland
visionärer langfristiger angehen könnten
und vor allem auch europäisch in der
frage klimawandel weiter gehen würde was
sagen sie denn vor konkret also mord
euro ticket für immer oder genau
also ich glaube zum einen was meines
erachtens verpasst wurde europaweit aber
auch in deutschland zum zum anfang als
jetzt die energiepreise gestiegen sind
und da sind wir wieder beim thema auch
bürgerbewegungen was kann ich denn tun
wenn jetzt also zunächst mal wenn die
energiepreise steigen zeigt das ja eine
knappheit im markt das heißt
signalwirkung okay was kann ich denn
jetzt tun um meinen energiekonsum so zu
reduzieren dass eben prinzip auf meine
kosten senken und ich glaube dadurch
dass wir als bürgerinnen und bürger dazu
nicht aufgeklärt wurden was es für
einfache maßnahmen eben einfach auch
gibt
ja wurde da im prinzip ein ganz
wichtiges instrument verfehlt ich glaube
zum anderen kann man natürlich so etwas
nutzen wie
reduzierte preise aber dann vielleicht
für gruppen wie studenten wie rentner
menschen die es wirklich so rauchen hat
hier angeblich jemand das nur ein euro
ticket sich eigentlich was ist wenn
jemand erklärte das leben das man dann
langfristig seien oder wenn sein auto
verkauft wird nur weil man jetzt
39 euro pro monat für öffentlichkeit und
zwar bundesweit
den regionalverkehr fahren von hier nach
sylt und sich nehmen
wir mal ganz kurz zwar noch
einmal ganz kurz es gibt ein
entlastungspaket 1 der bundesregierung
leistungspaket 2 der bundesregierung es
geht um das thema energie preise teuer
schock und darum bürgerinnen und bürger
zu entlasten da hat man sich unter
anderem ausgedacht als ampelkoalition
das ist für drei monate lang ein euro
ticket geben sie einen fahrschein für
neun euro im juni kostet neun euro im
juli kostet neun euro und im august noch
mal nen euro und dann können sie
bundesweit nicht in denen ics und ics
fahren aber sonst können sie bundesweit
im regionalexpress
auf die energie muss auch wieder
vergehen habe die fahrzeuge sollen
menschen aus dem auto von der strasse
haben sie es schon ich habe eine
umweltkarte also im bvg ticket und es
wird automatisch umgewandelt auf diesen
neuen euro aber das problem ist doch
dass der flug nach mallorca immer noch
viel zu billig ist und es heißt es
funktioniert über den preis am ende wir
unser verhalten verändert der markt wenn
ihr name in einer marktwirtschaft aber
die machen sie witze auf kosten der
natur auf kosten zukünftiger im
postkommunistischen staaten angeführt
dreck die sind ja da hat man keine wahl
sie in den letzten 150 jahren hier in
europa mehr treibhausgase ausgestoßen
als china natürlich erleben bei uns die
menschen aber auch länger wenn 85 jahre
alt hh mit algen flechten saison da
anzuknüpfen also was ich mir da auch
sehr viel sinnvoller vorstellen würde
also dieses entlastungspaket soll zwei
kommen über 25 milliarden euro kosten
wird dieser ich dreimal es ist gesamte
figur soll ja nur diese drei monate euro
das bedeutet also dass können wir glaube
ich sehr viel besser in
infrastrukturmaßnahmen in e mobilität
auf arbeiten sie weiter investieren
wir könnten zum beispiel europäisch auch
wirklich mal eine effektive co2
besteuerung angehen und
so abgesehen die clique dessen zukunft
wäre am ende müssen wir auch das noch
ein euro ticket bezahlen wir alle selbst
natürlich denn am ende muss der
steuerzahler bezahlt aber die frage die
man sich ja auch stellen kann beim
ganzen thema mitdiskutieren über
klimaschutz und wir diskutieren ist ein
bisschen mit augenzwinkern aber sonst ja
eine sehr wie ernst es ist klimaschutz
überhaupt dürfen wir gar nicht mehr
leben also herr davon möchte andere code
essen auch mal schnitzel brutzeln also
ist klimaschutz jetzt die abschaffung
eines lebensgefühls und auch des spaßes
am leben als schlau gewesen sein der
saison größere liebe noch zu einem
selbst zu seinem körper zu den
mitmenschen zu den tieren und zu den
anderen lebewesen mit denen wir hier
diesen planeten aber es gibt millionen
später mit dem wir uns diesen planeten
teilen im moment haben wir in den
letzten 50 jahren als menschheit mehr
zerstört auf als alle anderen
generationen vor uns und es geht so
nicht weiter schön dass sie ihre rezepte
niemals umsetzen werden können weil ich
setze jeder einzelnen sind auch in
berlin mainz eintreten gesellschaft
funktioniert sehr viel komplizierter
ihnen möchte ich mal eins sagen wir
haben heute ein ganz 3 wir haben
journalisten in der öffentlichkeit
stehende version ist sehr leicht zu
diskutieren und die beute über die
brücke her zu ziehen ich finde dass neun
euro ticket eine wichtige lösung zu
einem zeitpunkt wo in der bevölkerung
der frust so anstatt wegen der
benzinpreise und den täglichen preis
hypes auch in der bild zeitung dass die
vorkehrungen treffen müssen dass da
nichts zum beispiel nach rechtsaußen
sozusagen rattenfänger abschwimmen und
auch nach links außen die gibt es
nämlich auch mit verlaub die ehefrau und
das ist aus meiner sicht eine wichtige
maßnahme jetzt vor der sommerzeit da
sind doch keine idioten um herrn scholz
wir werden also prima minister an dem
daten jetzt haben wir mehrere
bundesländer weiter zu alles ist ja es
geht doch darum ich möchte daher
vielleicht an der stelle sagen dass ich
mich sehr bewusst dafür entschieden habe
letztes jahr im bundestagswahlkampf zu
kandidieren um nämlich genau
konstruktive lösungsvorschläge zu machen
ich glaube dass unser
bundeswirtschaftsminister zur zeit
unglaublich pragmatisch und lösungshilfe
habig
lösungsorientiert ist zum beispiel
direkt nach auswegen der alten oder noch
wäre würden bis zu unserer
energieversorgung
gesucht ich hoffe dass jahr bei der
europäische ansatz nicht verloren geht
indem wir als deutschland voran
schreiten ja ich hoffe dass wir europa
mitnehmen aber es ich darf doch trotzdem
eine maßnahme kritisieren ja wie auch
nicht auf
14 ende geht es nicht dafür dass die
lebensmittel oder 9 euro zug fahren oder
so weiter dass es billiger wird soll das
problem ist dass fliegen und tierischen
a und den viel größeren ökologischen
fußabdruck haben viel teurer serien bei
unseren nazi deutschland weniger als in
fast allen europäischen ländern und
deswegen gehen wir auch so
verschwenderisch mit lebensmitteln unter
anderem um weil wir es uns leisten
können jedes jahr dutzende textilien zu
kaufen und wegzuschmeißen weil sie so
billig sind wer würde die kleider und
auch die lebensmittel teurer sein würden
wir achtsamer damit umgehen was in den
handel über den preis was ist denn für
sie ein angemessener preis für einen
flug nach mallorca beispielsweise gerne
sagt man also ich denke mal der
realistische preis wenn man den
ökologischen schaden mit einberechnet
werden müsste fünf bis zehnmal teurer
sein nadine als weißen schicht und hat
ihr heute im wasser waschen wollen als
kleine geschichten wurden 1300 euro ach
so haben viel zu günstig viel zu günstig
die ökobilanz von einem ticket ja nie
viel verbrauchen und du hast gerade
darüber gesprochen wir brauchen
europäische co2 zertifikate die aber
auch im richtigen vernünftigen preis was
mich stutzig macht bei der frage ob
einer das auto einher nehme man den
ökologischen abdruck eines e-autos und
sage mal da ist jetzt atomstrom drin und
da ist windstrom drin also gar kein co2
ausstoßen ja keine kohle und kein gast
so und jetzt habe das in berlin hierher
gab von weiß das natürlich auch stellen
wir fest es gibt erste kitze die wollen
komplett autofrei sein wir bauen die
stadt quasi zurück und ist mittlerweile
völlig wurst ob das auto diesel in einem
dieselmotor fährt ob es ein benziner ist
oder ob es ein e auto ist was passiert
ist es gibt einen feldzug gegen das auto
mal eindruck ist auch es wird schlimmer
aktivistischen feldzug gegen das
flugzeug geben ist das völlig wurst ob
das mit grünem strom fliegt das flugzeug
oder mit solar wir sehen es beim auto
was passiert es spielt keine rolle was
werden parkplätze reduziert nicht für e
autos für sich aufgebaut und sie wären
insgesamt reduziert man will das auto
nicht mehr das ist offenbar in einer
gewissen gesellschaftlichen gruppe nicht
mehr en vogue selbst wenn der sauber
fährt und beim flugzeug sage ihnen
voraus wird das gleiche auch dass sie
also erst mal ganz kurz ein auto ist nur
weil das nur aus elektro energie
funktioniert ist es nicht sauber sondern
damit es hergestellt wurden hatte ich
erst mal so viel strom verbraucht und
das erste erstmal zehn jahre benutzen
muss damit man überhaupt sagen kann
jetzt kommen wir langsam zum break-even
also quasi eine positive ökobilanz
vorher habe ich einfach nur noch mehr
treibhausgasen im luft gebraucht noch
mehr ressourcen verbraucht was wir
brauchen ist viel weniger autos also
wollen wir
und ich glaube ist ein notarzt hat eine
mannschaft weil ein fahrzeug
normalerweise zu 95% schneider um steht
und wir müssen effektives system haben
um unsere ressourcen die wir haben
gemeinsam mehr zu nutzen und wir können
nicht jede 102 autos haben ob das neue
auto ist oder ein anderes das geht
ökobilanz technisch mit 8 milliarden
also need is nich es gibt keine autos
mehr irgendwann wie gehen wir
mit den zügen die züge müssen ja auch
immer hergestellt werden auch die
verbrauchen natürlich erstmal deswegen
sage ich ja es sollte nicht darum gehen
dass wir sagen alles soll jetzt gar
nichts mehr kosten soll es geht darum
dass wir den öko be die ökobilanz von
den einzelnen produkten in dem preis
realistisch wenn man gastwirt ist wenn
man spitzenkoch ist dass er das war dass
wir nicht ruhen welche metern hausherr
liebe vorstellt dass also die
autoindustrie am jahres 110 prozent für
den produziert was sie bisher produziert
haben dann stehen x1000 100.000 auf der
straße von 1800 auf der straße und ich
stelle auch über die frage aber ich bin
halt nur koch das elektroauto also
irgendwo muss das zeug ja auch passiert
wenn die energie und ich komme zurück zu
handys und laptops und ähnlichen dingen
ich komme auch zurück zu aufwendigen
herden und sofort also wir könnten auch
in der ganz schnell in der steinzeit
landen wenn wir wollen und dann gehen
wir im klub nürnberg alle gleich essen
sagen sie nicht mehr auffällt ist dass
das bdr zu ihrer schicht die burschen
haben müssen unsere genauso gehabt
überhaupt gar nicht dabei um vielleicht
irgendwie das noch mal auf einer anderen
ebene zu heben ich stelle mir die frage
in welcher gesellschaft wollen wir leben
und dann welche wirtschaft brauchen wir
uns in dieser gesellschaft zu gelangen
weil die wirtschaft ist kein selbstzweck
sondern sie es eben darum und als
gesellschaft
prima durch die jahrzehnte getragen
prima ihre generation hat ein thema das
immer noch aber ich bin
leider sehr lange nicht wussten was für
einen schaden fossile brennstoffe und
eben co2 ausstoß anrichten können und da
wir eine verantwortung haben also für
die nächsten generationen und auch
diesen planeten allgemeinen gegenüber
geht es doch es geht doch gar nicht
darum schön weit weg was sie sagen nein
das ist überhaupt nicht weit weg dass es
sogar sehr nah dran das ist es nämlich
jetzt schon realität auf die wissen sie
was derzeit produzieren müssen panzer da
rheinmetall und krauss maffei also sie
sind da ja auch ein leidenschaft der
diskutanten einlagen und gut ist sie
sagen ja auch völlig zu recht dass das
wirtschaftssystem was wir haben das
beste ist um dieses problem in den griff
bekommen wir dürfen ja einst auch nicht
vergessen verstärkt die co2 der co2
ausstoß im vergleich zu 1990 ist ja
bisher so reduziert worden wie
eigentlich die zielvorgabe war und 40
prozent darunter das wäre in der ddr und
im sozialismus nicht möglich gewesen das
hat das kapitalistische system richtig
die soziale marktwirtschaft oder
beziehungsweise marktwirtschaft mit
glücklicherweise starken sozialen
komponente in deutschland und ich glaube
wir schaffen das auch nur mit einer
marktwirtschaft in die klimaneutralität
aber wir müssen uns eben die frage
stellen was für einen preis sollte denn
klima lassen sie uns doch mal ehrlich
sein dass wir uns in
die arme von kalt unterhalt und von
afrika die für einen dollar am tag
arbeiten damit wir hier die löhne zahlen
können man muss doch mal irgendwie kurz
klar werden wohl das zusammenhängen aber
ist es sich so dass die regierung den
bildungsauftrag hat sowohl eine für eine
gesunde energie zu sorgen als auch für
eine gesunde ernährung zu sorgen und
damit dann müsse natürlich regel
geschaffen werden neu geschaffen werden
keine frage die tun aber ein bisschen
weh aber wir dürfen nicht immer nur in
weiß und schwarz denken ja und wenn wir
das auto wie sie eben gesagt haben
einfach in innenstädten abschaffen
ich bin nicht der meinung dass er der
letzte schluss sein wird stimmig weil
wir brauchen wir haben gesagt hat vor
haushalt ja das war doch auch sagen bei
allen dingen einer freien gesellschaft
möchte ich leben ja freien ohne
bevormundung aber auch das sagst du
schön auch dass ja natürlich zwei jobs
hat auch ohne dabei nicht einmal gucken
dass wir im also wer auf dem lande lebt
zwar autos hat er 22 jobs hat der
braucht möglicherweise etwa autos das
ist anders auch nicht hin zu bekommen
weil die busse auch nicht richtig fahren
sehen wollte es nicht sogar fünf
milliarden auch anders verwenden nämlich
in struktur investitionen auch auf dem
land und ich bin in der nähe von
frankfurt am main aufgewachsen auch ich
hätte mich ohne auto fast gar nicht
fortbewegen können weil in meinem ort
ungefähr dreimal am tag ein bus vorbei
kam
also die realität sieht so aus dass nach
luft ringt wie gute lösungen finden aber
ich glaube auch dass uns nichts bringt
einfach nur zu sagen da die wirtschaft
so wie sie ist es doch gut so und wir
bleiben jetzt einfach dabei weil hiermit
alle bist du weil weil sich leider die
rahmenbedingungen verändert haben und
das müssen wir einfach das schlusswort
frau sternberg